- [Instructor] We are told
the population of a town
grows at a rate of e to the 1.2t power
minus two t people per year
where t is the number of years.
At t equals two years,
the town has 1,500 people.
First, they ask us
approximately by how many people
does the population grow
between t equals two and t equals five,
and then what is the town's population
at t equals five years.
If we actually figure
out this first question,
the second question is actually
pretty straight-forward.
We figure out the amount that it grows,
and then add it to what we
were at at t equals two,
add it to 1,500.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
The key here is to appreciate
that this right over here
is expressing the rate of how fast
the population is growing.
And we've then seen in
multiple videos now,
let me just draw, do a quick review
of this notion of a rate curve.
So those are my axes, and this
is my t-axis, my time axis.
And so this is showing
me how my rate of change
changes as a function of time.
Let's say it's something like this.
So once again, if I said at this time
right over here, this is my rate,
this doesn't tell me, for
example, what my population is.
This tells me what is my rate
of change of a population.
And we have seen in previous videos
that if you wanna figure
out the change in the thing
that the rate is the
rate of change of, say,
the change in population,
you would find the area
under the rate curve between
those two appropriate times.
And why does that make sense?
Well, imagine a very small
change in time right over here.
If you have a very small change in time,
and if you assume that your
rate is approximately constant
over that very small change in time,
well, then your change in,
let's say we're measuring
the rate of change of population here,
your accumulation, you could say,
is going to be your rate
times your change in time,
which would be the area of this rectangle.
And so roughly that would
be the area under the curve
over that very, very small change in time.
What we really wanna do is
find the area under this curve
from t equals two to t equals five.
And we have seen multiple
times in calculus
how to express that.
So the definite integral
from t is equal to two
to t is equal to five of this expression
of e to the 1.2t minus two t dt, dt.
So, if we just evaluate
that, that will be the answer
to this first question.
So what is this going to be?
Well, let's actually work it out.
So what is the antiderivative
of e to the 1.2t?
Well, let me just try to do it over here.
So if I am trying to calculate,
let me write it as e to the
five, or actually 6/5 t.
Say, 12/10 is the same thing as 6/5.
6/5 t dt, so this is
an indefinite integral,
I'm just trying to figure
out the antiderivative here.
Well, if I had a 6/5 right over here,
then use substitution, or
sometimes you would say
the inverse chain rule,
would be very appropriate.
Well, we could put a 6/5 there
if we write a 5/6 right over here.
5/6 times 6/5, then we can take constants
in and out of the integral like this.
Scaling constants, I should say.
Well, now, so this is
going to be equal to 5/6,
this 5/6 right over here.
This antiderivative is
pretty straight-forward.
Since I have the derivative
of 6/5 t right over here,
I can find the antiderivative
with respect to 6/5 t,
which is essentially I'm
doing u-substitution.
If you have to do u-substitution,
you would make that
right over there u, and then
that and that would be your du.
But, needless to say, this would be
5/6 times e to the 6/5 t,
and if you're thinking about
the indefinite integral,
you would then have
a plus c here, of course.
And you could verify that
the derivative of this
is indeed e to the 1.2t.
So this is going to be equal to,
so this part right over here,
the antiderivative is 5/6 e to the 6/5 t,
and then this part right over here,
the antiderivative of two t is t squared,
so minus t squared.
And we are going to evaluate
that at five and two
and find the difference.
So let's evaluate this at
when t is equal to five.
Well, you are going to, and let me
color-code this a little bit.
When t is equal to five you get
5/6 times e to the 6/5
times five is e to the 6th
minus five squared, so minus 25.
And so from that I want to subtract.
When we evaluate it at two we get
5/6 e to the 6/5 times
two is the same thing
as 12/5, or we could say that's 2.4.
2.4 minus four, two squared is four.
And so what do we get?
Well, there's a couple of
ways that we could do this.
So then we could write this
as, let me write it this way,
we could write this, so
we have a 5/6 and a 5/6,
so we could write this as
5/6 times e to the sixth,
e to the sixth, minus e to the 2.4,
minus 'cause we distribute
that negative sign,
e to the 2.4, e to the 2.4 power.
And then we have minus 25,
let me just get another color
to keep track of it.
We have minus 25, and then
you have minus negative four.
So that would be plus four.
So that would be minus 21.
And I would need a calculator
to figure this out,
so let me do that.
Let me get my calculator on this computer.
And, there we go.
And so let's see, if we wanna find
e to the sixth power, that's 403, okay,
now let me figure out,
so minus, I would say,
20, 2.4, that looks like
a 24, I'll correct it
as soon as I get back to that screen.
E to that power, e to the 2.4 power.
And I get equals, so what's in parentheses
is this number right here, so times 5/6.
Times five divided by six
is equal to that minus 21.
Minus 21, is equal to this.
So, if I round to the nearest
hundredth it's going to be
approximately 306.00.
So this is approximately 306.00.
So approximately by how many
people does the population grow
between t equals two and t equals five?
Well, by approximately 306 people.
Let me write that down.
So approximately 306 people.
And they say, what is
the town's population
at t equals five.
Well at time two at two
years we had 1,500 people.
And then we grow over this
interval by 306, so plus 306.
Well, that's gonna get me to,
we deserve a little bit of a drum roll,
1,806 people at t equals five years.